con estas canicas los gambianos eligen
este sábado a su futuro presidente este
inusual método de votación que consiste
en dejar caer esferas de cristal dentro
de las urnas fue introducido en la
década de los años 60 para evitar que se
estropearan las papeletas en una nación
con un alto índice de analfabetismo
son las primeras elecciones democráticas
en este país de apenas 2 millones de
habitantes enclavado dentro de las
fronteras de senegal desde que la
autócrata yahyá jammeh se viera obligado
a exiliarse en enero de 2017 derrotado
en las urnas por adam a barrow su
partida a guinea ecuatorial puso fin a
un gobierno de 22 años marcado por
crímenes y abusos en el campo en
términos de libertad de expresión ahora
es mejor antes no era así tras las
elecciones anteriores la votación se
desarrolló con normalidad siempre es
después del recuento cuando empiezan los
podremos adam avaros se enfrenta a cinco
candidatos de lo que se espera que sea
una carrera reñida su intento de
reelección se da pese que el actual te
ha decepcionado a muchos
nos dijeron en 2016 que si les vota
vamos traerían puestos de trabajo para
los jóvenes pero desde que llegaron al
poder no vemos ningún empleo en gambia
de gambia su principal opositor es el
veterano político usted en un árbol
cuando queremos votar a dar voy porque
siente nuestro dolor él no va al cargo
para enriquecerse porque ya lo tiene
todo al máximo y aunque esta vez y yahyá
jammeh no consta en la papeleta a su
sombra sigue acompañando el escenario
político en una serie de discursos el ex
presidente instó desde el exilio a
respaldar una coalición dirigida por el
candidato mamá can de los primeros
resultados de las elecciones podrían
anunciarse este domingo